the Hallberg Greenwell and I'm the head
of the National Science Foundation's
office of legislative and public affairs
I would like to today to introduce
today's distinguished panel dr. France
córdova director of the National Science
Foundation Shephard Dolman is the event
horizon telescope project director of
the Center for Astrophysics Harvard and
Smithsonian Dan Maroney is an event
horizon Telescope Science Council member
and an associate professor of astronomy
at the University of Arizona
Avery Broderick is a member of the event
horizon telescope board and wheeler
chair of theoretical physics at the
Perimeter Institute an associate
professor at the University of Waterloo
and Sarah Murkoff as a member of the
event horizon Telescope Science Council
a professor of theoretical physics at
the University of Amsterdam and she
coordinates the EHT multi-wavelength
workshop we will have time for questions
after the panel concludes so please hold
all questions until that time I will now
turn it over to dr. Cort Abbas
good morning thank you for joining us at
this historic moment I'd like to give a
special welcome to the director of the
White House Office of Science and
Technology Policy dr. Kelvin Drogo Meyer
and from the National Science Board the
current chair Diane su vain and former
chair Maria Zuber today the event
horizon telescope project will announce
findings that will transform and enhance
our understanding of black holes as an
astrophysicist this is a thrilling day
for me black holes have captivated the
imaginations of scientists in the public
for decades in fact we've been studying
black holes so long that sometimes it's
easy to forget that none of us has
actually seen one yes we have
simulations and illustrations thanks to
instruments supported by the National
Science Foundation we've detected binary
black holes merging deep in space we've
observed the
sadiq transfer of matter from companion
stars unto black holes some massive
black holes create Jets of particles and
radiation we've spotted the subatomic
neutrinos those Jets can fling across
billions of light-years but we've never
actually seen the event horizon that
point of no return after which nothing
not even light can escape a black hole
how did we get here through the
imagination and dedication of scientists
around the world willing to collaborate
to achieve a huge goal through a large
pool of international facilities and
through long-term financial commitments
from NSF and other funders willing to
take a risk in pursuit of an enormous
potential payoff without international
collaboration among facilities the
contributions of dozens of scientists
and engineers and sustained funding the
event horizon project would have been
impossible
no single telescope on earth has the
sharpness to create an unblurred
definitive image of a black hole's event
horizon so this team did what all good
researchers do they innovated more than
five decades ago other nsf-funded
researchers helped lead the development
of very long baseline interferometry
which links telescopes computationally
to increase their capabilities this team
took that concept to a global scale
connecting telescopes to create a
virtual array the size of the earth
itself this was a Herculean task one
that involved overcoming numerous
technical difficulties it was an
endeavor so remarkable that NSF has
invested twenty eight million dollars in
more than a decade joined by many other
organizations in our support
as these researchers shaped their idea
into reality
I believe what you're about to see will
demonstrate an imprint on people's
memories the event horizon project shows
the power of collaboration convergence
and shared resources allowing us to
tackle the universe's biggest mysteries
and now I'm going to hand over this to
our distinguished panel starting with
dr. Sheppard a'lamin eh T's director
[Applause]
thank you assembled guests blackhole
enthusiasts black holes are the most
mysterious objects in the universe
they're cloaked by an event horizon
where their gravity prevents even light
from escaping and yet the matter that
falls on to the event horizon is
superheated so that before it passes
through it shines very very brightly we
now believe that supermassive black
holes millions even billions of times
the mass of our Sun exists in the
centres of most galaxies and because
they are so small that we've never seen
one they are though they can outshine
the combined starlight of all the
Constituent stars in those galaxies the
best idea we have of what they can look
like come from simulations like this the
infalling gas that's superheated lights
up a ring of light where photons orbit
the black hole and interior to that is a
dark patch where the event horizon
itself prevents light from escaping
the event horizon telescope project is
dedicated to the idea that we can make
an image of this black hole we can set a
ruler across this shadow feature measure
the photon ring and test Einstein's
theory where they might break down it
also will allow us access to a region of
the universe we can study precisely the
energetics and how black holes dominate
the cores of galaxies to do this we work
for over a decade to link telescopes
around the globe to make an earth-sized
- the aim is to outside the the
televising telescope but she is the
highest angular resolution possible from
the surface of the earth it's the
equivalent of being able to read the
date on a quarter in Los Angeles when
we're standing here in Washington DC in
April of 2017 all the dishes in the
event horizon telescope swiveled turned
and stared at a galaxy 55 million
light-years away
it's called Messier 87 or m87 and
there's a supermassive black hole at its
core and we are delighted to be able to
report to you today that we have seen
what we thought was unseeable we have
seen and taken a picture of a black hole
here it is
this is a remarkable achievement what
you're seeing here is the last photon
orbit what you are seeing is evidence of
an event horizon by laying a ruler
across this black hole
we now have visual evidence for a black
hole we now know that a black hole that
way is 6.5 billion times what our Sun
does exist in the center of m87 and this
is the strongest evidence that we have
to date for the existence of black holes
and it is also consistent the shape of
this shadow to the precision of our
measurements with Einstein's predictions
the bright patch in the South you see
tells us that material moving around the
black hole is moving at light speeds
which is also consistent with our
simulations and predictions and this
image forges a clear link now between
supermassive black holes and the engines
of bright galaxies we now know clearly
that black holes drive large-scale
structure in the universe from their
home in these galaxies and we now have
an entirely new way of studying general
relativity and black holes that we never
had before and as with all great
discoveries this is just the beginning
the imaging of black hole doesn't come
easily I can tell you that from personal
experience as can many people here in
the audience it's required long term
developments a committed team but it
also required some very interesting
cosmic coincidences take for example the
the Maelstrom you see before you like
the hot gas whirling around the black
hole a photon has to leave from close to
the event horizon travel through the hot
gas in falling to the to the black hole
and light rays of a millimeter
wavelength radio waves can make that
journey not all of them can then that
radio wave has to propagate 60,000 years
through the m87 galaxy and then another
55 million years through intergalactic
space and then it winds up in the
Earth's atmosphere where its greatest
enemy the greatest danger is it will be
absorbed by water vapor in our own
atmosphere so the event horizon
telescope uses telescopes at high dry
sites so we can see the photons that are
traveled to us so far so so far so good
we have the we have the photons
but the m87 shadow is very very small
compared to the galaxy that surrounds it
so in order to see it we needed to build
a telescope as large as the earth itself
given the wavelength of light we were
trying to observe and to do that we use
a technique called very long baseline
interferometry which you can see a
schematic of here radio waves from the
black hole hit radio telescopes where
they recorded with the precision of
atomic clocks that lose only one second
every 10 million years when you've
registered these radio waves so
precisely you can then store them in
hard disk drives send them to a central
facility where they can be combined
precisely it's exactly the same way that
a mirror used at an optical telescope
reflects light perfectly and in
synchronicity to a single focus and when
we do this we can synthesize a telescope
that has the resolving power as though
we had one the size of the distance
between these telescopes truly turning
the earth into a virtual telescope all
the sights that we used can be seen here
we have telescopes from Hawaii to
Arizona to Mexico to Chile to the South
Pole and on in Spain but even these even
this broad global network is not enough
by itself to make an image you can think
of them as being silvered spots on a
large global mirror the key is that the
earth turns during a night of observing
we are able to sweep out more baselines
more coverage of this virtual mirror to
make our image so on the left you'll see
the earth turning every pair of
telescopes provides us with one point on
the center panel which fills in the
Earth's eyes virtual lens and on the
right you see the evolving image the
more and more data we get the more we
fill in this virtual mirror the sharper
our view of the black hole becomes until
you wind up seeing what we have as the
final image there so we've taken
advantage of a cosmic opportunity it's
remarkable when you think about it light
that left near the event horizon
travelled all the way through
intergalactic space it hit our
telescopes the earth just happens to be
the right size so we get resolving power
so that we can see the black hole in m87
whose mass and distance let us observe
and then the earth turns to fill in our
mirror so that we can make this image
it's really remarkable it's almost
humbling in a certain way now we are
four members of a large collaboration
and is our distinct honor to be here to
represent that collaboration we are 200
members strong there are 60 institutes
and we are working in over 20 countries
and regions we consider ourselves really
to be explorers through international
cooperation and innovation we've exposed
part of the universe that we thought was
invisible to us before it's our
responsibility now to report these
findings and we're doing that today to
the National Science Foundation to our
funding agencies international and
foundations and to all people who
support pioneering research and also to
the taxpayers
Nature has conspired to let us see
something that we thought was invisible
this is a long-sought goal for us and we
find it tremendous and we hope that you
will be inspired by it too thank you and
now Lavigne reduce Dan Maroney
who has literally gone to the ends of
the earth to collect some of the data
that we've seen here today
[Applause]
thanks show so there we go
so the heart of our measurement is of
course the EHT array it would have been
an expensive enormous undertaking to
build a dedicated array just to do this
experiment so we didn't do that instead
we built an international partnership
that allowed us to use sub millinery
telescopes all over the world in fact we
used basically all the sub millionnaire
telescopes in the world to make this
measurement one that none of them could
have done on their own when you take a
heterogeneous collection of telescopes
and build them into one giant telescope
it presents a lot of technical
challenges and so in the years leading
up to our 2017 experiment we went
telescope by telescope all over the
world
installing the specialized hardware we
needed to do this most of the telescopes
had detectors that we could use but
almost none of them had the atomic
clocks we need and certainly none of
them had the very fast data recorders
that we use some places we had to do
even more a good example of this is the
Alma telescope in Chile it's a 66
telescope array it's by far our most
sensitive telescope and its sensitivity
is transformational for our experiment
but in order to use it we didn't just
need the basic hardware we also needed a
special piece of hardware that could sum
the light from all the telescopes before
we sent it to our recorders this alone
was a many year project using an
international collaboration of people
from the EHT and also from the Alma
project another good example is the
South Pole telescope the South Pole is a
special place in our a it's so far south
that it doubles the resolution of VHT
four sources it can see but the SBT was
designed to do a completely different
kind of measurement it studies the
Cosmic Microwave Background and so it's
detectors are not the detectors we need
so in addition to bringing down an
atomic clock in all the tens of crates
of hardware that we needed we had to
build a special receiver that would
detect the light the way we needed
did special optics to relay the light to
it and install it and get it to work in
the cold then sometimes harsh Antarctic
environment this was many years of work
for many of us many trips down for
myself and graduate students in postdoc
and other engineers in the EHT team but
at the end of it we had a South Pole
telescope that could be any HD station
now getting the sites to work isn't the
end of the process we also had to test
them all because in VLBI you really only
get one shot everything has to be
working exactly right when you win the
script starts so we spent years taking
site by site pairing them up and making
sure that our VLBI observations would
work the last of these observations was
in January 2017 by March of 2017 we knew
that that test had worked and we were
ready to go the image that Shep showed
was from April 2017 and for that
campaign we sent our team to the
telescopes all over the world their job
was to turn everything on do very
extensive testing and then be there to
do the observations but even with all of
that in place we still had to wait for
weather and my experience with 10 years
of doing these observations is that
weather is usually the place where we
fail we have to have good weather in
Hawaii in Spain at the same time in
Arizona and the South Pole and that's a
lot to ask but in 2017 we were very
lucky our first three days of
observations were some of the best
weather we've ever seen and for a ten
day campaign we were done in only seven
taking all the data we wanted at the end
of that we had five petabytes of data
recorded it was recorded on more than a
hundred of these modules and it amounts
to more than half a ton of hard drives
five petabytes is a lot of data its
equivalent to five thousand years of mp3
files or according to one study I read
the entire selfie collection over a
lifetime for 40,000 people
the image you saw though isn't 5
petabytes in size it's a few hundred
kilobytes so our data analysis has to
collapse this five petabytes of data
into an image that's more than a billion
times smaller we do that in many steps
first of those steps is to get these
modules to our correlators in Westford
Massachusetts and bonn germany the
fastest way to do that is not over the
internet it's actually to put them on
planes there's no internet that can
compete with petabytes of data on the
plane once they're there the correlators
job is to find the exact same wavefront
of light arriving it from the black hole
at each telescope once it's found small
timing corrections that line up those
waves we can condense our data we can
average it and we reduce our data volume
by a factor of a thousand now we're at
terabytes a much more familiar unit but
we have a lot more work to do the data
still have imperfections at that point
both from the instruments themselves and
from the atmosphere above the
telescope's and so we do something
called fringe fitting we actually do
this in the cloud with cloud computing
which lets us do it in days instead of
weeks we calibrate the data so that we
know exactly how bright our sources are
and I'm speaking of this as though it's
just computer work but this was actually
a very significant project for a subset
of our team primarily junior people
postdocs and graduate students and they
deserve an enormous amount of credit for
their diligence and dedication because
without it we couldn't have made an
image once we're done with that we can
finally go to the imaging stage now
imaging with an interferometer isn't as
simple as downloading a picture from
your camera the fortunately though the
math that we use for it has been around
for more than 200 years the principle is
well understood the methods though as
with everything with this project are a
little tricky for our data and so in
order to get to the image there's been
years of image algorithm development
within our team that's been essential to
our results at this point in history we
have many different image algorithms to
choose from they have different
strengths and weaknesses it
just depends on the character of the
data and so the way we approached the
imaging stage is we set up four teams
all over the world they were
collaborating each team is representing
many parts of the world and we told them
don't talk to each other or anyone else
choose whichever imaging algorithms you
think are best and make images of these
data and then in the summer of 2018 we
brought everyone back together at a very
exciting meeting the HD imaging workshop
in Cambridge Massachusetts if you
couldn't be there you certainly called
in from the internet because you wanted
to see the presentation and in a very
exciting presentation we revealed to the
other teams and to ourselves what we'd
found and what we saw in those images
were four very similar pictures looking
almost exactly like the one you see
today an emissive ring surrounding the
shadow of a black hole it was a
wonderful day of science and I'm glad
that after a few more months of very
careful checking and paper writing that
we're finally able to share it with you
today and now I'd like to hand off to my
colleague Avery Broderick to talk about
the interpretation
[Applause]
thank you damn it is an enormous
pleasure to be with you this morning to
share in this extraordinary moment as
Shep said we have now seen the unseeable
now what does it all mean every Photon
in these first EHT images began its
journey in a turning Maelstrom embedded
in the most extreme environment in the
known universe the vicinity of a black
hole and m87 the crucible in which these
photons were born was powered by the
black hole in two distinct but related
ways first by an accretion flow a
violent disc of orbiting gas driven
inextricably toward the event horizon by
the time the material is making its
final plunge it is crashing into itself
at nearly light speed transforming the
gas into a hundred million degree plasma
second through astrophysical jets a
narrow beams of out flowing material
speeding away from the black hole at
nearly the speed of light these Jets are
powered by black hole's spin rotating
black holes drag everything gas magnetic
fields and photons about themselves
driving these paradoxical structures
whose cosmic importance will be
discussed by my colleague Sarah Markov
and m87 one of these Jets has pointed
very nearly toward us the EHT images are
influenced both by these bright emitting
regions the rotating accretion disk and
outflowing Jets and by gravity itself in
general relativity radio waves fall just
as Apple's do typically this effect is
exceedingly small but black holes are
gravity run amuck the radio waves we see
in these first images orbited the black
hole before beginning their fifty-five
million years Ernie toward us this
results in the dark shadow or silhouette
casts
by the black hole's event horizon upon
the emission from the accretion flow in
the jet
importantly the size and shape of the
shadow is determined by gravity alone
general relativity makes a clear
prediction for both of these features to
within 10% the shadow should be circular
with the diameter determined solely by
mass multiplied only by fundamental
constants however as with all voyages of
discovery when we began this expedition
of the mind we did not know what we
would find where Einstein wrong or the
the object at the heart of m87 not a
black hole its silhouette could have
been very different miss shapen or miss
sized like those seen here or even
simply missing changing gravity changes
how light bends and thereby changes to
the shape of the shadow in April 2017
this was the dog that did not bark the
shadow exists is nearly circular and the
inferred mass matches estimates due to
the dynamics of stars a hundred thousand
times farther away today general
relativity has passed another crucial
test this one spanning from Horizons to
the Stars the shadow is surrounded by a
bright ring of enhanced emission Oh
enhanced a mission to do those photons
that just escaped the black hole's
clutches the properties of this ring
like feature results from the
Astrophysical dramas that unfold on
gravity stage to understand these dramas
over the past three years the EHD
collaboration has undertaken an
unprecedented simulation effort at
research institutions across the globe
this has generated the largest
collection of simulations ever assembled
of the accretion flow and jet launching
region in m87 the southern brightness
excess arises directly from near light
speed rotational motions near the black
hole regions that move toward us at
nearly the speed of light are bright
those that are moving more slowly or
away
from these we have inferred the sense of
rotation of the black hole in m87 the
black hole spins clockwise
moreover the excellent quantitative
agreement between EHD images and generic
theoretical expectations of a bright
Crescent like feature with the dark
interior provides significant confidence
in our interpretation the object at the
heart of m87 the object that powers m87
jets is a black hole like those
described by general relativity
importantly in combination with infrared
and optical flux measurements we can now
rule out a dim but otherwise visible
surface that is this does indeed appear
to have the defining feature of a black
hole the event horizon that point of no
return today several complementary
windows have opened upon black holes
science fiction has become science fact
together two of these windows the EHT
and LIGO which reported the first
detection of gravitational waves a short
three years ago have verified another
key prediction of Einstein's theory of
gravity
despite varying across a factor of
billion in mass known black holes are
all consistent with a single description
black holes big and small are analogous
in important ways what we learned from
one necessarily applies to the other at
this point I would now like to hand the
story off to Sarah Markov who will
describe the broader Astrophysical
implications of these first EHD images
[Applause]
Thank You Avery so black holes may be
the most exotic consequence of general
relativity but these bizarre sinkholes
in the actual fabric of space-time turn
out to be have a lot of consequences of
their own which I'm going to talk about
today
that's because black holes are major
disruptors of the cosmic order on the
largest scales in the universe
they're actually helping mold the shape
of galaxies and clusters of galaxies
well we've now confirmed as Avery was
saying the general relativity itself
does not change when we look at
different black hole masses it turns out
that the impact of a black hole will
actually change a lot and so if we want
to understand the role of black holes of
the universe then we need to have
accurate determinations of the black
hole masses and this has been a problem
up until now so actually our our mass
determination by just directly looking
at the shadow has helped resolve a
long-standing controversy in measuring
the mass of m87 there's been two
independent methods one both basically
looking at the motions of either gas or
stars but they ended up giving different
answers our determination of six and a
half billion solar masses lands right on
top of the heavier mass determination
from stellar motions and so this
actually will also help resolve a
discrepancy that can lead to better mass
determinations for other more distant
black holes where we can't actually see
the shadow so getting to the impact of
this is important because many sevens
huge black hole Maps makes it really a
monster even by supermassive black hole
standards so you're basically looking at
a supermassive black hole that's almost
the size of our entire solar system and
in fact that's part of the reason that
we can see it even though it's so far
away but if we now zoom back out to the
more cosmic perspective of the host
galaxy of this black hole the galaxy is
made of billions of solar systems and so
on those scales the black hole self is
minimally small it's about a hundred
million times smaller than the galaxy
and if it were a dormant black hole like
the super mass
black hole in the center of our own
galaxy Sagittarius a star then the
galaxy would really have no way of
knowing it's there and would basically
be just like a pebble in a shoe but when
a black hole is what we call activated
by gravitationally capturing material it
starts to convert that fuel into other
forms of energy with an efficiency that
can be almost a hundred times better
than nuclear fusion that powers the
stars like our Sun and so when that
happens in these active phases black
holes temporarily become the most
powerful engines in the universe and
they go very quickly from being a pebble
tissue to a thorn in the side of the
galaxy
literally and the thorns in this case
being the Jets that Avery was mentioning
in the most extreme cases these Jets can
actually penetrate to the entire galaxy
and well beyond but the power that's
coming out we can't see with our own
eyes so if we want to understand them we
have to look in other wavelengths so we
look with telescopes across the
electromagnetic spectrum so I'm going to
give you an example of this this is
another very active black hole system
and it's a combined image so you see in
white from NASA's Hubble telescope the
elliptical galaxy Hercules a in the
center and then overlain and blue is the
radio waves from the National Science
Foundation's Very Large Array and these
radio waves are basically tracing
magnetic fields in space so this tells
us that these Jets are just enormous
fountains of magnetized material that
are being sprayed out from the black
hole not the black hole itself but near
the black hole nearly at the speed of
light and these particular Jets are a
hundred million times bigger than the
black hole that launches them now if we
add another layer we're gonna look in
the x-rays now from NASA's Chandra
telescope and x-rays are probing
extremely hot gas like billions of
degrees so we're seeing the entire
system is embedded in a halo of hot gas
and we can use this information to
calculate how much energy the Jets have
to have to bore through all this
material and what we find is that the
Jets are carrying the equivalent of 10
billion supernovae in energy deposited
over one of these active cycles so this
is you know these kinds of interactions
are basically very
important because this tiny black hole
on these scales is somehow launching
these structures and also managing to
heat the gas to prevent stars from
forming and since galaxies grow by
forming more stars this has the effect
of truncating galaxy growth and we think
it's through these types of interactions
that black holes help shape the largest
structures galaxies and clusters of
galaxies and make them look the way they
do today
now m87 is in a much more modest active
state but as you can see this is also
from Hubble there's still managing to
launch pretty magnificent Jets and these
Jets are emitting across the
electromagnetic spectrum as well so we
need this information to be able to
fully understand the system but if we
zoom way out now to the cluster of
galaxies scales this is another combined
image where you see red in radio and
blue an x-ray you see just a mess of
structures and we think this is telling
us about and many seventh black holes
past interactions really affecting the
clusters wheels on timescales of
hundreds or you know tens of hundreds of
millions of years so until now well we
always thought that black holes were
behind these large structures driving
these engines but we never knew and now
with EHT we have direct evidence of the
root of these problems and we can look
at this and we can now start to make to
understand there we go
combining strong gravity magnetic fields
and looking at atomic level processes to
understand how these processes interplay
and conspire to make these enormous
structures that are basically affecting
the largest scales of the of the
universe and so to capture all this
information we need to combine our
observations with those across the multi
wavelength spectrum and so as you heard
from damn there's a lot of complexity in
these observations that we added to that
by doing a complicated Sudoku of
coordination with many facilities across
the globe and also in space and this is
similar to the campaign that was run
with LIGO for gravitational waves it's
very important to combine signals both
from photons and particles and so by
doing this we expect that EHT is going
to play an active role in this new era
of international multi messenger
astronomy
so anyway looking to the future the same
observations that we took in 2017 that
for m87
also included this dormant black hole in
our galactic center Sagittarius a star
and by looking at two black holes at
opposite extremes of this activity range
especially combining this with
multi-wavelength information we can
better understand the Evan flow of
influence of black holes in the long
course of our history the universe
anyway so thank you very much I'm gonna
hand this back over to chef who's gonna
say a few words thank you everyone I
just want to point out that when we
first started the event horizon
telescope project the group was small
and I think it had to be small and
nimble to carry out precursor
experiments and developed the first
kinds of techniques and instrumentation
that enabled us to to move the field
forward
but over the past decade the greatest
accomplishment has been the building of
a team as I said before we're now 200
people strong many Institute's over 20
countries and regions and if you want to
reduce petabytes of data if you want to
develop new imaging algorithms if you
want an image a black hole then you need
a large team and it is included many
early career scientists senior
scientists and many of them are here
with us today so I'd like to ask
everyone who's associated with the event
horizon telescope to please stand up so
that everybody in the media can see who
has done this work
[Applause]
it's a it's a true pleasure and
privilege let's work with this crew and
I urge all the media to please go seek
them out to learn how the sausage was
actually made how the black holes were
actually imaged I also want to say
something in particular about funding
and support this has been a high risk
but high payoff endeavor sometimes you
have to kiss a lot of frogs before you
get the prints before you get the if the
black hole image and you need supporters
you need funders who will stand by you
for long periods of time who take the
long view who understand that basic
science never goes out of style and who
also understand that you know basic
science you never know when it's going
to pay off but ultimately it usually
does and that you have to play the long
game and we had wonderful partners with
the National Science Foundation with our
international funding agencies and
foundations and our hats off to them for
sticking by us for so long and we look
forward to greater things with the EHT
as we build out the capability and we
continue to sharpen our focus on black
holes
thank you all very much
mm one note before we take questions
seller of our panelists and many of
their EHT collaborators will appear this
week in a documentary which has followed
the efforts of EHT for the past two
years the film will show viewers just
how chef Dolman and his team reached the
groundbreaking moment the documentary is
called black hole hunters and it will
premiere excuse me this Friday April
12th at 9 p.m. Eastern on Smithsonian
Channel we will now take questions from
the audience until 10:00